group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV
I'm P Morgan on sensored tonight in Los
Angeles more bombshell court documents
and more lury claims about pedophile
Jeffrey Epstein's powerful friends but
who knew what and when I'll talk
exclusively to his brother and Donald
Trump appears in called again but are is
mounting legal woes making him ever more
popular I sit down with a Democrat
presidential candidate who says Biden
never mind Trump is unfit for
office
[Music]
this is Pier Morgan
uncensored good evening from Los Angeles
welcome to peers Morgan uncensored
Jeffrey Epstein was a pedophile he was
also very rich and friends with some of
the most powerful people in the world
they flew on his private jets they pared
at his home on Fifth Avenue they
holidayed on his now Infamous Caribbean
island we know that Gilla Maxwell his
ex-girlfriend and longtime fixer traff
young women and underage girls to that
Island for Epstein to sexually abuse we
also know that Maxwell a woman is the
only person so far to be held
accountable for the heinous Deeds of a
sick man whose crimes must have been
abetted by at least some of his male
friends what we still don't know is
exactly who else knew about it when they
knew about it and why they decided to
turn a blind eye those who knew Epstein
before his conviction may have some
plausible deniability certainly possible
they orbited his lavish world without
knowing what he was really really about
but what about after that Epstein was
first arrested in 2006 and in 2008 he
played guilty to his listing
prostitution from an underage girl he
got 18 months in jail but he cut a
secret deal with the US attorney that
meant he avoided federal charges they
let him leave prison during the day to
work from his own office then released
him five months early that now looks
like a massive slap on the wrist for a
Serial sex offender and well pretty much
a deal with the devil so how did he get
that
why did so many people including prince
Andrew the late Queen's favorite son
continue to call him a friend afterwards
was I right in in in having him as a
friend um at the time and bearing in
mind this was some years before he was
accused of being um a sex offender um uh
I I don't think there was anything wrong
then the problem was the fact that once
he had
been convicted you stayed with him I
stayed with him and that's that's that's
the bit that that that that um as it
were I kick myself for on a daily basis
because yeah that was a problem like
most of Prince Andrew's answers to the
questions on the subject it just didn't
Stack Up it defies credulity to claim
that none of the men in Epstein's life
knew that he sexually abused young women
and as more and more legal documents are
unsealed the picture gets only murkier
there are many lurid claims and emphatic
denials documents released yesterday
surfaced discredited allegations or
maybe they're not discredited we don't
really know that Epstein had sex tapes
of prince Andrew and potentially of
former presidents Bill Clinton and
Donald Trump and even Sir Richard
Branson although his spokesman said that
the claims are baseless and unfounded
and they may well be this is exactly how
conspiracy theories start and are
allowed to prosper there are many many
unanswered questions about Jeffrey
Epstein and many important people who
are choosing not to answer answer them
well joining me now via phone call
because he would prefer not to be seen
on camera is Jeffrey Epstein's brother
Mark
Epstein Mark Epstein thank you very much
indeed for joining me um let me first of
all ask you what did you know about your
brother and it's an obvious question but
you are his relative his sibling um when
this all came out about him were you as
shocked as everybody else or did you
have concerns about him well back in
2006 when he first got into trouble he
told me that he was getting into trouble
you know for what he was doing and uh so
so I knew from early on what was
happening I uh yeah so he told me early
on did you know the scale of it I mean
obviously he had that conviction he
served time in in prison but the sheer
scale of I made it real clear I made it
real clear I'm not discussing anything
about my brother is charging against him
I have nothing to do with that I wasn't
involved I have no more information the
only thing I'm interested in discussing
is the circumstances surrounding his
murder okay well you say it's a murder
obviously it was ruled as suicide why do
you believe that's not
true well first the the actual
pathologist who did the
autopsy uh did not determine it was a
suicide they couldn't they said it
looked more like a homicide but on the
death on the initial death s
on cause of death it said pending
meaning pending further investigation
which is proper and then a few days
later you know Bill bar claims it was a
suicide and then the chief pathologist
of New York who did not see the body
claims it's a suicide so the point the
question becomes what investigating was
done in a matter of days to make them
come out with that determination and it
turns out that because it was called a
suicide there doesn't seem to have been
an investigation because if you declare
somebody died by Suicide there's really
nothing to investigate you the only
questions about a suicide is how did
they do it did they hang themselves did
they shoot themselves did they jump out
of a window and that's a pretty obvious
answer at the time of the death so
there's no investigation was done the
EMTs that went to the prison were never
questioned the hospital Personnel were
never questioned we can't seem to find
the medical records we can't get the 911
call if this was a suicide why are all
these things
hidden and why I mean obviously make
that ridiculous
statement right let's talk about the
night that your brother died he was
found hanged what is it about what
happened that night that well yeah well
okay he that's what was reported so tell
me why you think that what happened that
night is so suspicious
okay first of all for four years we were
trying to find out what position his
body was in when he was found because
that that's very Telly uh but we
couldn't find out because they moved his
body after he was found uh to the
infirmary of the prison when the EMTs
were called and they got to the prison
he was already dead in the infirmary
understand something he had been dead
for at least two hours before he was
found that's what the autopsy showed and
that's not a question that's a fact he
could have been de for 6 hours but at
least two now they said in the doj
report that finally came out that he was
found hanging they said he was in a
seated position with his legs extended
in front of him and when he was and tied
to the top bunk and when they either cut
him or tore him down his buttocks was an
inch and inch and a half off the ground
which if you picture that it means
basically his entire body weight or the
bulk of his body weight was hanging by
the neck yes there was probably some
weight on his feet at the end of his
legs but the bulk of his body was
hanging now the mark on his neck left by
the
ligature is in the middle of his neck
and go straight back if he was hanging
as they said the ligature would have
slid up high up under his chin and then
went up back sort of behind his ears up
to the whatever he was tied to so the
ligature mark on his neck is
inconsistent with the way they describe
him and another important thing is that
when you die when a person dies you know
their blood isn't circulating anymore
and what happens The Blood starts to
settle in the body to the lowest point
gravity just takes the blood you know
through the tissue so you get a pooling
of the blood under the skin which which
is why they tell you to never move a
dead body because they can tell a lot of
things if you find a dead body laying on
its face and the back has its lividity
with cool blood that means the body died
on its back and somebody eventually
turned it over so if you picture the way
they describe Jeffrey as hanging well he
should have lividity in in the back of
his legs and in his buttocks which was
the lowest part of his body okay if he
let me ask you this if he didn't take
his own life who do think took it who
killed him in your estimation it's a
good question you know Bill bar said
that no one would in there out of the
Tia so he concluded it was a suicide but
there were something like 11 or 12 other
prisoners on that tier that could have
went in and killed him now if another
prisoner killed him it's s of why would
they go to the exent to cover it up you
know it's like if if you remember the
case of Whitey buer he was in prison and
he got killed by three other they well
they got the guys and they prosecuted
him for killing whitey buer in jail if
it was just another prisoner that killed
Jeff why would they not just find out
who it was and prosecute him for murder
there doesn't seem to
be a reason to cover that up also we
can't get a list of who were those
prisoners that were already on the tier
we know I know one was the kagon who was
Jeff's you know cellmate for a while now
the question becomes who was on the tier
that night when were they put there and
when were they transferred out because I
was told that after the death a number
of prisoners would transferred off of
that tier to other places so let me ask
you mark let me ask you do you do you
believe obviously Jeffrey your brother
had uh relationships friendships with
many many of the most rich famous
powerful people in the world do you
believe that you know if let's take this
this Theory to uh
a conclusion here do you think that one
of those people who may have had a
vested interest in shutting him up and
not talking about what he knew about
them potentially may have played a part
in his
death yes that's what I think happened
and then you have to question out of the
Rich and powerful people he knew who
would have the ability to pull something
like this off that's another question
who would have the ability to plant
somebody in there if that's the way it
was done who would have the ability for
the to have the justice department come
up with this you know pardon the
language his report you know in
the Justice Department report it just
says that it was declared dead by the uh
pathologist but that's not true it was
it was declared undetermined by the
pathologist that did the actual report
and then for some
reason yeah you you've claimed uh Mark
Epstein that your brother had
information on Donald Trump and and Bill
Clinton that were so inury that the 2016
election would have been cancelled if
that information had come
out what was that information that's
wait wait yes that's incorrect What
Jeffrey told me during the 2016 election
we were just discussing the election
just two brothers talking about current
things uh he what he said was that if he
said what he knew about both candidates
they'd have to cancel the election so he
was talking about Donald Trump and he
was talking about him because Bill
wasn't running at that point in time and
and and Jeffrey used to sometimes tell
me things about people he was with
whatever I never heard Jeffrey say
anything bad about Bill Clinton Jeffrey
always liked Bill Clinton he admed Bill
Clinton so I I don't think that uh you
know again he didn't say he had
information on Bill Clinton he he
mentioned the candidate so I want to
keep the record straight I like to keep
facts out there not speculation what
information what information do you
think he had on Donald Trump for example
that could have uh
disqualified specific inform I don't
know any specific information but I've
also heard Jeffrey say that he stopped
hanging out with Donald Trump when he
realized Trump was a crook that's on
tape I I heard a videotape interview
with Jeff and he
said that he stopped hanging out with
Donald Trump when he realized Trump was
a
crook do you believe that there are do
do you believe do do you believe that
there are these videotapes which came
out of the un sealed documents yesterday
that there are videotapes uh which
apparently were from cameras that your
brother put in place recording famous
people from prince Andrew to Bill
Clinton to Richard Branson and others
having sex on tape do you believe that
you know I I've heard those stories and
it's sort of like doesn't matter if I
believe it or not I don't know so again
I I shy away from speculating on things
I have no backs on okay I I was told by
somebody who supposedly knew that there
were not cameras in the New York house
you know I know there were cameras that
around arounded entryways and for
security I was told there was no cameras
inside but again I don't know if that's
how reliable that I thought it was
reliable you know and I don't have any
reason to to doubt it but again I don't
want to speculate so so I have no
knowledge of any tapes or
anything okay Markin I appreciate you
joining me thank you very much you're
welcome love well I'm joined Now by
Gloria Ed who represents over 20 of
Jeffrey Epstein's victims Gloria uh what
did you make of that conversation with
Mark
Epstein well I like the fact that he was
fact-based I do think there is quite a
bit of uh rumor conspiracy theory uh
filling the vacuum of you know the facts
that didn't come out as soon as they
might have uh so I still think that
there are a lot of questions about
whether it was a su Sude whether it was
a
homicide uh whether it was some kind of
natural death I I don't know it I know
there have been you know a report I
Believe by the uh you know many
investigations which decided or
concluded that it was a suicide but I
think there's still an open question I
remember seeing Jeffrey Epstein the last
time he appeared in court in New York
and I know that many of the victims that
I represented 20 that I represent many
of those 20 were hoping and expecting
that there would be uh other hearings
other you know in the prosecution that
was taking place of him and they were so
thrilled that finally there might be
some justice in the case in the criminal
justice system of course uh his death uh
ended in in a way that was and at a time
that was so unexpected and was
devastating to many of the victims who
hoped to be able to confront him in that
court of law in federal court in New
York what people who don't know Jeffrey
FC just know all these rumor mill stuff
and some of it's true some of it isn't
you know it's hard to really piece
together the reality here about him what
is your belief about Jeffrey Epstein
Gloria well definitely I called him I
call him a child sex abuser uh a sex
trafficker of underage girls and uh
that's what of course uh galain Maxwell
was charged with and was convicted in
federal court uh I by the way I never
use the word pedophile because that
means a lover of children and a man who
exploits and hurts and traffics uh and
uh you know does what he did to underage
girls and so often to adult women as
well is not a lover of children is not a
lover of women he's a
manipulator uh and uh he's a a a sex
predator there's a lot of ongoing
speculation about Prince Andrew's uh
friendship with Epstein and what he knew
or didn't know uh the bottom line is he
paid Virginia jefra a reported $1
million to settle a case with her that
he said he was never going to settle uh
what what do you read into that I mean
is there any way in a normal world that
somebody would pay someone that amount
of money to stop a case proceeding if
they didn't have something to hide I've
done
countless uh settlements after
litigation or what we call
pre-litigation
and the accused person never uh admits
that he did it but when we do it uh you
know we present a great deal of evidence
to the accused to through his lawyers
and uh and then there is a process often
a mediation process with a retired judge
or a professional mediator where there's
conversation which is really a
negotiation and there's a result so
bottom line I can't say whether he did
it or not but it certainly raises the
question if he paid
substantial uh millions of dollars to
resolve and settle the
case glor roid as always great to have
you on the program thank you very
much thank
you br on sensor next I'll beginning
more on this story with my panel
including 's former lawyer Alan
DZ
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
schort today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an o in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
of money it's cost we're saying what are
we saying it's cost about 140 million
140 million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald mcmouse man MC
mous man MC Mouse man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign yes CU I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call terror group is it
possible to have a rational I've asked
you two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
welcome back to un sensor from Los
Angeles let's get more now on the
bombshell court documents about
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein's powerful
friends joining me now as his former
lawyer and the author Alan dtz the
investigative journalist Vicky Ward and
Fox News host Tommy Len well welcome to
all of you Alan d let me start with you
you've obviously your name has has
appeared in these unsealed documents in
various places um what should we read
into these documents there's so much
claim counter claim denial suspicious
silence in some cases what should the
public make of
it well first I want every document to
come out every single one I want every
videotape to be revealed I hope there
are videotapes of every single sexual
encounter that anybody ever had in any
property of Jeffrey Epstein and I hearby
wave any right of privacy because I know
I did nothing wrong I had sex with one
woman from the day I met Jeffrey Epstein
till the day he died my wife and these
tapes have revealed exculpatory material
Sharon churcher for example there were
emails that showed that she put my name
into the head of Virginia gofy she said
although we know dtz didn't do anything
wrong he didn't we didn't we couldn't
prove anything against him
it would be a good name for you to put
in your book because he's famous he
represented Claus vulo a movie was made
about him and then she put me in her
book as somebody she did not have sex
with so you know these disclosed
materials have helped people who are
falsely accused by me they don't help
people who have been truthfully accused
there's another woman named Sarah Ransom
who also now it's been disclosed that
she claimed to have sex tapes of Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump and now she's
admitted that she made the whole thing
up so it's a very good thing that these
tapes and these pictures and these
emails have come out I want more to come
out there are FBI reports I've seen an
FBI report but it's redacted there are
tape recordings that are relevant to the
Innocence or guilt of people who are
accused the one thing we shouldn't do is
engage in McCarthyism we shouldn't do
what McCarthy did he held up lists and
said if your name is on the list you're
guilty my name is on the list of course
it is I was his lawyer but my name is on
the list in an exculpatory way and so
I'm very pleased that these materials
have come out I want more to come out we
filed a brief the other day in court
demanding even more information to come
out because all the information will
prove that I did nothing wrong I was his
lawyer if you don't like that well then
complain about our legal system but I
never had any improper relation with
anybody connected to Jeffrey Epstein or
anyone else you mentioned Sarah Ransom
there she is one of Epstein's victims
and she made the claims about the
existence of these sex tapes then she
did retract them but interestingly she's
now come out and doubled down on her
original claim in an interview with my
old show Good Morning Britain let's take
a look there are videos that
exist the people that know they
exist um I'm sure very frightened of
them being released so how do you know
then that Epstein had cameras on the
island it's no secret that everything
was
recorded multiple victims have come
forward confirming my account along with
others I've also seen recordings in his
office well Vicky Ward you you actually
met uh Sarah Ransom uh it's hard to know
where the truth lies given that she has
said one set of uh claims then she's
retracted them and now she's doubled
down on the original claims what do you
think well I think if you listen to her
Lang language just there appears she's
not quite doubling down on the specifics
of the original claims she's just saying
there are tapes she's not saying
specifically of who I think look Sarah
Ransom in 2022 published a memoir called
silence no more which you know will have
had to have gone through pretty rigorous
legal vetting and factchecking and none
of the specific allegations that we read
uh in the document D yesterday are in
there and Sarah Ransom was not uh a
witness or an accuser taking the stand
in gilen Maxwell's criminal trial
Norwood Virginia Roberts
nonetheless the pattern of behavior that
both of them
described did form the
backbone of the substance being
discussed at that trial and I think that
is why it's important for other victims
were the were the victims who took the
stand in Gillen Maxwell's trial they
also by the way got things wrong when
they were first interviewed by the FBI
uh they then either forgot it or or or
or had to sort of say they'
misremembered it when when under
cross-examination it happens with
stories of extreme sexual abuse it does
all of this does make it really hard for
journalists like us to sort out the
wheat from the chaff and this story you
know the whole the Jeffrey Epstein story
Still Remains a huge mystery because you
know in these latest filings we get this
lurid picture into endless depravity the
man seems to have had so much sexual
activity a day it leaves you wondering
when he had time to do anything else and
if he didn't have time to do anything
else then why were all these really
important powerful world leaders
floating around him there are lots of uh
questions here that are still
outstanding yeah I mean Tommy luren
looking at this in totality you've got a
guy that was clearly a Serial abuser
often of underage girls doing it in
plain sight whilst also maintaining a
position as financier and socialite
friend of the most rich powerful famous
people on Earth and yet the only person
so far who's been brought to Justice
over any of this is his former fixer
gillain Maxwell not a single man has
been brought to account here despite the
Welter of evidence that they were all
there at the time a lot of these people
what do you think of
it well I'll tell you this money is
power and we know from looking at
Hollywood especially over the last 10
years we've had more Revelations thanks
to the me too movement which is very
selective by the way that pedophiles and
predators protect one another because
Hollywood and places of power DC
included are crawling with predators and
pedophiles that's why it's taken so long
for us to get this information that's
why so many have protected not only
Epstein but have protected the logs that
have protected these document dumps from
coming out we get redacted versions We
Get sensationalism with names being
thrown around but will we ever really
get to the bottom of it will we ever
really get to the bottom of what
happened to Jeffrey Epstein a lot of us
are confident we ever will because we
understand what I said predators and
pedophiles protect one another and the
fact that Hollywood and the elites have
been coddling this man and this
information for so long tells you
everything that you need to know about
the inner workings the dungeons that
make up Hollywood DC and political
Elites around the world they protect
each other Alan do you believe that
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself or do you
believe as his brother said earlier that
he was murdered well I don't know for
sure I think he had a motive to kill
himself he couldn't stand the idea of
spending the rest of his life in prison
but the circumstances demand
investigation I don't believe if he
committed suicide he did it by himself
he would have had to pay off I think
some of the guards I think some of the
guards have been disciplined everybody
who has any culpability should be held
responsible I'm on the same side as the
victims in this case I want all the
evidence to come out so that the true
victims are Vindicated but I also want
the evidence to come out that shows that
there are some credibility questions
about people like Ransom and others You'
said that prince Andrew shouldn't have
settled with Virginia G fre n Roberts
obviously uh why do you believe
that well even if everything they said
about him was true she was over the age
of consent um she bragged to people
about how wonderful it was and to pay
millions of dollars for that a a jury
would never have come back that way and
I think he could have won the case on
legal grounds but I suspect that he was
concerned about what would happen during
a deposition not about necessarily the
person who accused him but about his
whole life because depositions are wide
open I think it was a terrible mistake
for prince Andrew to have uh settled the
case I wish he could reopen it because I
don't think there was jurisdiction in
the federal court I don't think that
there was uh the statute of limitations
were satisfied there are all kinds of
legal issues that he could have won on
but I suspect his mother did not want
the embarrassment that would have come
out had he sat for a deposition okay
Vicky um you've worked extensively for
Vanity Fair one of the emails that came
out was between Virginia jefra and
Sharon churcher suggesting that Bill
Clinton had stormed into the Vanity Fair
offices and threatened them not to write
a sex trafficking expose of Epstein do
you have any knowledge of that do we
know if that actually happened did
Clinton do
that I've never heard that and I know
that Gren Carter who was the editor at
the time has categorically denied it you
know what did happen and and what I
think sort of probably made its way in a
convoluted ultimately inaccurate form to
Virginia um many years later writing
that email was that Jeffrey Epstein
appeared in the Vanity Fair offices um
and uh had a conversation the contents
of which I've I've never learned but it
was while my article on him was being
fact checked and supposed to be closing
and all I know remember I was on bed
rest uh pregnant with my twins at the
time I was not in the office was that at
the 11th uh the allegations of Maria and
Annie farma were cut from the article um
so I think that
somehow Virginia learned a version of
what had happened that was that was
wrong Tommy finally look at the politics
of this normally you'd say one side
could latch onto it the other side could
latch on to it it's the problem here is
you've got prominent figures on both
sides you've got Republican icons like
Donald Trump you've got Democrat icons
like the clintons and so on is this a
kind of situation where actually a
staying on all their houses no one can
really get political gain from this
Scandal yeah I think that you know this
as well as I do peers that if Donald
Trump were implicated in anything
illegal or anything nefarious that would
be the first thing that would be
explored to the 20th degree because
Donald Trump can't breathe without them
indicting him so I think actually Donald
Trump's being name being mentioned but
nothing really Beyond a mention I think
that goes to show that Donald Trump is
probably very innocent of doing anything
nefarious or anything awful because if
he had that would be you know another
stain on him and the media runs to do
that at every opportunity if they could
I think we both know they absolutely
would Tommy Len Alan dtz Vicky Ward
thank you all very much indeed this
Scandal will run and run we may never
actually get to the truth sadly but I
appreciate you joining me on sus the
next he's a presidential hopeful who has
had many heated debates over the Israel
Hamas war on this very show I sit down
with The Young Turks host Jen yuger here
in LA to talk about the war the Epstein
files Trump and why he thinks so Biden
is also unfit for office
that's
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about talk today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see see this coming
around the tracks with sella bravman
she's heading up one side and richy soon
at the other the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swearing off in the police to act
without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes R unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be Trust sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
un Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call her possible is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV he's one of the biggest Liars in the
history of global politics I was raised
Catholic so that makes me Jewish you
clearly dressed up in Dr once I ran in
2020 for the same exact seat I got away
with it then now he's been expelled from
America's Congress and he could face up
to 20 years in jail the expulsion of the
gentleman from New York Mr Santos did
you not think people would find this out
I've bit a terrible liar can George
Santos finally tell me the truth from
Los Angeles here's Morgan an
[Music]
sens welcome back to uncensored from Los
Angeles when the news of jeffre Epstein
suicide was announced Jake yuger the
massively popular Young Turks Network
said if you were trying to set up a
conspiracy this is how you do it so what
do you think about his revelations in
this incredible story and about the US
presidential race where he's a candidate
I sat down face to face with Jen to get
his take on it uh and the ongoing war of
course between Israel and Mass on which
he's been very vocal Jen it's great to
see you here in Los Angeles I feel like
we've we've been seeing each other from
across the water uh often in very quite
tense and fractur circumstances with big
debates so it's good to see you just
one-on one I'm going to come to Israel
I'm going come to the US election you
course are running for president but
first let talk about the Epstein Scandal
which every single day seems to produce
ever more lurid headlines what do you
make of it well it's important because
it's people in power that did terrible
things and seem to have largely gotten
away with it so I like that people care
about accountability on this issue the
problem is we don't really know exactly
who did it and ex
what they did so you know you've got
Bill Clinton saying I was on the plane
but I wasn't on the island you got
Richard Branson who's come out vly
denying there's any sex tape of him as
was supposedly revealed uh yesterday uh
there's lots of claim counter claim
going on very little hard evidence which
is indisputable which could lead to
potential consequence yeah so when he
first died in in prison I thought okay
there's going to be something that's
determinative here did the video in the
hallway in the prison work or did it not
work if it worked and we see that no one
went into his cell okay then it's a
suicide I'm you know I don't I'm not
particularly fond of conspiracy theories
Etc but if it didn't
work okay well then that's a totally
different issue and as it turns out oh
golly gee the guards were off and the
video didn't work well that leads you to
many other speculation by Nature of this
Beast right but look even Trump trump
said was terrific friends with Epstein
for a long long time and said he knows
that epin likes them young so there's no
question that he knew that epin was up
to terrible things but did he do it I
don't know it's easy for the two sides
to say Clinton definitely did it Trump
definitely did it political game playing
going on with the various names and
different attitudes depending if if it's
one of your party uh there's also I
think with with the Epstein Scandal a
sense that you look at it in totality
you have Epstein who was in jail and may
have taken his own life or may have had
it taken from him we'll probably never
know the only other person who's been
brought to account is gilay Maxwell his
kind of Madame figure in the whole thing
none of the other men who must have
either known about Epstein's
proclivities or actively joined him in
some of them have ever been properly
brought to book for this do you think
they ever will well hard to tell but one
of the things that uh makes me wonder
and why I brought up the videotape in
the prison is because Epstein was
supposed to have videotapes of a lot of
this and yet we magically still haven't
found the videotapes and under the Bush
Administration the guy who let him go
wound up by the way being the labor
secretary for Trump he's the one that
let mste off the hook in the first place
right back in 2008 so magically everyone
keeps getting let off off the hook in
this case except gain Maxwell and of
course on that one Trump said that he
was very fond of her also i' seems to me
there sort of life before his first
conviction and life after it I before
the first conviction then you can
completely believe that people may have
been you know conned by this guy but
once he had that
conviction in the early 2000s for you
know effectively a sex crime with a
minor you know pedophilia once that
happened everyone who then continued to
deal with him from prince Andrew onwards
uh they surely are coupable by
association yeah I think after 2008 you
have no excuses at all and and everybody
I remember covering that story and I
remember saying this is ridiculous this
is a slap on the wrist for a guy who
might have done an enormous amount of
pedophilia and been connected to at the
time we already knew he was connected to
tons of people in finance politics
people in power after that going back
and still associating with him probably
means you're an addict probably means
you you youve you're not only don't mind
that at all but can't help but go and
seek that out and what about that deal
that was done at that time I mean it was
such
a murky Looking Back Now terrible deal
with the devil it seems in the epine
case you have this guy who says oh this
cholester serial child molester is going
to serve a short time in prison but he's
not even really going to be in prison
he's going to get to go out during the
day and still conduct business and still
make a lot of money will it have any
bearing on the election this year
probably not because a uh people on both
sides are implicated uh and of course
they're treated differently right the
Republicans think it's only Democrats
because they have a Mind Freeze on
anything that involves Trump even though
Trump says I was great friends with him
he's a terrific guy he said back in the
day and I knew that he likes him young
right they're like nope I don't hear it
I'm magga let's come to the election
you're running uh for president I mean
do you do you genuinely have any belief
you could win what is your real purpose
for running yeah so I have three
missions so let me tell you the first
one which is Joe Biden's going to lose
and I need to push him out he's at 33%
right now no one has ever recovered from
being that low as an incumbent for any
federal office let alone president
he's down 14 points with Independence
he's down four points with younger
voters he's down five points with
Latinos it is a disaster for Joe Biden
and right now if we don't get him out we
are definitely going to lose to Donald
Trump he's losing every single swing
state we have to act now to get new
candidates in and that's mission number
one he would say I beat him last time
look Piers I can give you a 100 stats
but the bottom line is no one with an
approval rating this low has ever won
for any f federal office when they were
this far down in an election season that
means Joe Biden would have to pull off
the literally the greatest political
comeback in American history does anyone
in their right mind think he's capable
of that there's no way he can do it how
much of Biden's unpopularity is specific
to his age in other words if he was a if
he was Gavin Nome who was currently the
incumbent president with the record that
Biden has had in the last three years
would he be polling much higher so yes
and no uh a lot has to do with his age
77% of Americans have said that they are
concerned that he will not be healthy
enough to finish a second ter but that
is not the only issue so in office how
is he done you know people say oh my God
he he did more than a normal Democratic
president that is a very low bar
democratic presidents barely try so did
he do most of his agenda no 85% of his
agenda is dead and there's no dispute
over that it's incredible to people
outside of America that Donald Trump who
lost last time has been pretty much a
consistent loser in the electoral
process since 2016 he's now facing
nearly 100 criminal charges and yet all
that has done is fuel him and make him
more popular allow him to play the
victim and see his poll numbers go up
what does that say about America and Jo
political system so Donald Trump
reserves almost all the criticism that
he gets and he breaks so many laws that
he floods The Zone and then you don't
know what to respond to because he said
something maniacal here he broke that
law there he's a lifelong criminal Etc
but the number one issue is the one that
the media doesn't talk about which is
he's anti-establishment
that's why people like him Democrats
underestimate him at their Peril and
they don't over and over again so
there's three issues here one is yes he
did do all those things and sometimes
there Democrats overreach anyway right
number two is what you're pointing out
which is that he's telegenic he not in
terms of looks but in terms of he's
entertaining he's charismatic yes and
what Democrats don't understand is sorry
but politics is now all media Wars
that's what it is where do people get
the information on who they're going to
vote media some form of media not
necessarily mainstream media but some
form of media so you have to engage in
the media Wars and Trump is fantastic at
engaging in the media Wars he goes to
wherever the cameras are he grabs the
spotlight what does Biden do Biden made
his first speech against Trump just a
couple of days ago what are you waiting
for brother he's done 200 speeches in
the time that you've done one that is a
colossal media advantage and hence a
colossal political Advantage but the
third part of it is he's giving a giant
middle finger to the establish now I
don't want Donald Trump to win I'm in
this race EV why do I want to knock
Biden out because I don't want him to
lose to Trump if Biden is the candidate
do you think Trump wins if he wins the
Republican nomination it's near 100% so
look and what would that mean for
America disaster total epic disaster
even Republicans who don't support Trump
are now supporting him in large numbers
because they believe the Democrats have
overreached in the way that he's being
prosecuted and I can understand that
it's the same way they Tred to take him
off the ballot my first reaction was why
would you do that all that does is make
him more popular and by the way the
Supreme Court inevitably will throw this
anyway there's still folks uh that I
have a lot of adjectives for I'll try to
keep it under control that still say 91
indictments well all it's done has made
them more popular when are you going to
get it through your thick thick skull
that people don't think like you do so
this normal person who's a liberal in
Washington is like well I am outraged
and I would never vote for anyone with
91 indictments yeah brother but you're
not the average voter the average voter
doesn't see it that way and hasn't seen
it that way and the polling has showed
it for nearly a
year we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police appr Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million1 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden this decided this was important
after watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes than going to do you're
going to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible have a rational I've asked
you two questions should aass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that let's turn to Israel and the war in
Gaza we've had some very emotive debates
involving you and many other people had
a little break uh you come back now to
see nothing's changed on the ground
perhaps the world's attention is less
obsessively now and there than it was
what is your take on where we are with
this war yeah so today we read that uh
that Israel's going to start to withdraw
a little bit from Gaza we'll see I'll
believe it when I see it uh Israel has
been brutal uh they've now killed about
20 times the number of people that Hamas
did uh I don't believe that a state is
immune from charges of terrorism or
genocide they say well we're a state so
we don't we can't when we murder
civilians it's perfectly kosher sorry it
isn't Israel is dropping 2,000lb bombs
and a lot of them are unguided what that
means is I don't give a damn who it
kills I don't care if it's a terrorists
which by the way are mainly under the
tunnels what I laughed at was the idea
that they killed 10,000 Hamas Fighters
no one we IDF has shown through their
own videos that the tunnels are largely
intact we know Hamas is in the tunnels
so they in all log IC and evidence
indicates that they barely got any Hamas
Fighters I I don't actually think Hamas
has shown by its behavior in the last 17
years where they've had power in Gaza
that they have any real concern for the
welfare of Palestinian no I I don't
think they do Hamas is Muslim
fundamentalist and so whenever you have
oppression unfortunately fundamentalism
grows that's a great bre there can't be
a future with Hamas in charge can yeah I
don't think so no so who I mean let's
cut to the quick here about How This
Ends people talk about the day after the
war how do you think this ends and what
is the smartest way for everyone to go
forward when the war is over so let let
me handle that in two ways the current
path that Israel is on is uh well Hamas
made us kill all your kids that's an
absurd thing to claim if you're so
powerful why is Hamas making you kill
their civilians that's absurd and then
they say oh we're going to the war ends
when Hamas surrenders nobody thinks
they're going to surrender that's an
absurd standard what are they going to
say okay I'm right here come and bomb me
come and arrest me so there but there is
a real way that it can end so you make a
deal with the Palestinian Authority and
the Biden Administration has finally
woken up and begun to go in this
direction totally discredited riddled
with corruption that's right I mean I
would say Hamas is also responsible I
would say that Netanyahu is very damaged
he may not survive this himself and he
is at the behest now and under control
of his
right-wing cabinet which is incredibly
unfortunate for those like you and I who
would like to see peace be achieved here
how long do you think this war is going
to come on for so we have a problem with
Netanyahu on our second front which is
that he's corrupt he has these charges
he's lost the Israeli population and I
don't want people making assumptions
about Israel and the people that live
there look at how unpopular Netanyahu is
with his own population right and there
is there is no democracy in Israel
overall because they imprisoned 5
million Ians but there is democracy
within Israel itself for them right and
within that democracy you have a vibrant
media Etc that criticizes Netanyahu so
the reason why I say Netanyahu is
primarily responsible is because even if
you blame Hamas and that's fair well
he's the one that aided and embedded
Hamas he's the one that helped them get
funding he's the one that thought it was
a brilliant idea to have them as a
counterweight to the Palestinian
Authority the problem is the polls show
that whilst there's a lot of
unpopularity for Netanyahu and he would
certainly lose an election if it was
held tomorrow on that basis and a lot of
it is driven by they blame him for what
happened on October the 7th there's also
widespread support in Israel for what
the IDF are doing in terms of response
so you have these two things running
concurrently Netanyahu personally very
unpopular but what the IDF are doing
under his command as prime minister is
very popular yeah so look there's two
issues one is nyaho is in charge and is
and we don't have elections and we can't
get them out even though the Israelis
want them second want him to get out the
second issue is you're right it's not
just Netanyahu problem it's an Israeli
right-wing problem and right now the
rest of his C is a bunch of monsters
ghouls and goblins who are openly
brazenly talking about ethnically
cleansing the Palestinians in ways that
are sometimes even more vicious than
Netanyahu and talking about starting a
war in Lebanon starting a war in Iran
that is insanity Total Insanity so look
at some point if the Israeli population
does not choose peace we're all doomed
doed for endless war in the Middle East
but if the Israeli population in an
election chooses peace for the first
time since the
sakine then all of this can be solved
and we can end this thing forever Jake
great to see you all right great to see
you really good to to chat over the
issues I wish you all the best for 2023
thank
[Music]
you we're here thanks for joining us
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the the referendum that he
said he would deliver the Israelis are
very conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and rishy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for liit
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan should have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out
vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in last three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC Mouse man
MC mous man mous he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this is important after
watching a Tom Cruz film do you think
people underestimate how important music
is for this country it's about 10 times
the size of